in addition to being the screenwriter
Daniel you're the the nephew of the the
folks we just watched on screen it's
only some of them
Martin Ginsberg was my mom's older
brother right and as I understand it the
sort of idea for the script happened
Martin Ginsburg's funeral service is
that right bring everyone down I'm sorry
yeah yeah a friend of uncle Martin's got
up and gave just a beautiful eulogy in
which he briefly mentioned the only case
that Ruth de Marty ever argued together
and and he did so in the context of
because to the end of it I mean
literally the very end of his life uncle
Martin said that the most important
thing he had ever done was hand Ruth
that tax cordovan sheet because it
allowed her to do the things that she
had done and that was the first time I
heard the story and I was pretty newly
married at the time my wife and I very
consciously had said out loud we want to
be like Ruth and Marty that's what we
want our marriage to look like and so
when I heard that story I thought wow
that would make a great movie that was
my first thought my second thought was
what kind of [ __ ] am I I'm sitting
here at my uncle's funeral minding his
life for material you can't do
screenwriter deeply understood in this
room I'm sure um
Felicity one of the things that's unique
about Ruth Bader Ginsburg is her
speaking boys and I was running if you
could talk a little bit about how you
found that voice uh yeah it's um it was
interesting I mean early on I was
obviously incredibly nervous playing
such a huge icon and as someone who's so
beloved and being a fan myself it's
quite an interesting process how do you
play someone that you you absolutely
adore but obviously you have to find the
idiosyncrasies and the edges of that
person but I mean in terms of voice I
had a decision quite early on in the
sense of do I play obviously Ruth as she
is now at 85 is oh come on
this gentleman Mimi leader leader in the
house
[Applause]
hi it's Justin here not with me it'll be
the next thing just talking I thought
you had an interesting choice to make I
what do they wanted to hear about oh yes
yeah so basically it was do I play the
voice that everyone knows so well which
is Ruth at 85 years old which was very
different from the recordings that we
heard and the early the early recordings
of her in court and her voice then
became such a way into the character and
I thought no I have to have to stick to
the truth of how that voice was that I
heard in those recordings and it was
interesting in showing me how Ruth
wasn't just fighting in terms of her
gender in terms of her faith but but
also in some respects because of where
she was from and there was a there was a
bit of snobbery around that so in the
court you know in that time in the 1950s
you were kind of expected to have quite
a standard accent and so it's
fascinating to analyze her literally I
spent a lot of time thing about Ruth
Bader Ginsberg's vowel sounds which
which you would hear these little
moments when she gets upset or she gets
frustrated in court and these this there
would be the stronger Brooklyn sounds
would would come through but it was yeah
it was just so useful cuz obviously we
know her so well from 1993 and she's
been in the public eye so it's very much
about finding the clues to how she was
when she was younger before she became
the icon she is today and I have to tell
you as someone who is known Ruth Martin
Ginsburg for my whole life
these two are just uncanny and the roles
that's really the work that you guys did
in the town he put into it thank you
army I wonder if you had occasion to
think about why in an era when so many
men had really traditional ideas about
gender roles
Martin Ginsburg apparently was much more
open why do you think that was I think
it speaks to a strength you know I think
I think it's it's very easy to dismiss a
man who did all that as well you know
and we just got done doing press in your
and it was really funny because some of
the older journalists they'd say things
like well you know he was kind of a weak
man and you know blah blah and I was
like okay you're really outing yourself
here fella but but I think it's I think
I think the opposite is true you know I
mean this was a man who was willing and
able to defy the gender norms of the
time you know in the 50s 60s and 70s men
rarely stayed home and cooked and
cleaned and helped around the house it
just really wasn't the done thing but he
was so secure not only in himself but in
the equal partnership that he had with
Ruth you know I mean they they had a
very progressive relationship for now
and and even much more so in the 60s and
70s I think it was the fact that he
understood the symbiotic relationship of
the long or the symbiotic nature of a
long lasting relationship he he also
knew that what Ruth was doing was
important I mean the fact that he set up
until he died that the most important
thing he did was ever hand her that tax
book it shows that that he recognized
the importance of his wife's mission and
what he she was doing and and that he
really saw a dignity in the nobility and
and found joy in doing whatever it took
to help facilitate and be sort of a
buttress for her Michael can you talk
about writing a theme for a character
like Ruth Bader Ginsberg how did you how
did you think of her musically well I
think when Mimi and I first sat down and
and she showed me the movie you know
that the beginning is so inspiring this
Harvard marching band and this idea of
you know the there was something about
that band the the excitement the forward
momentum and the rhythm and the and the
sound of evolution and the sound of time
going forward so and Mimi kind of threw
me into the deep end right away often I
like to start at the beginning the film
and kind of go through it kind of Q by Q
but Mimi wanted me to very early on kind
of attack really the the turning point
in the film where Ruth looks at her
daughter and realizes we don't need to
change hearts of mind the change has
already happened it's right here in
front of me
and then the brief writing montage so we
wanted to kind of attack that right away
and I think it would end up to be a
great thing because when I watched the
movie I was so inspired and kind of
excited and a lot of that feeling went
into that anthem that that you know I
wrote for that and and so that's the
sound the sound of of this forward
momentum but also we enjoy turning kind
of the cliches on their head often you
know the sound of drums and brass and so
on is something and that's the Paula G's
anymore coming or we've probably got
like Justin yeah so that the sound of
you know that's kind of a male sound and
it's kind of a sound of the
establishment so we really enjoyed kind
of turning that on its head and making
that Ruth sound the sound of snare drums
and brass and an energy and confidence
and and the the true kind of essence of
American progression first we have the
50s in Boston and we have the 70s in a
number of different cities how did you
create it where did you create it well
we shot in Montreal and one day in DC
and we shown it in 34 days and you know
I wanted the film to have a contemporary
feel even though it definitely is in its
period and I wanted it to have deep
colors and a very strong palette and
feel contemporary but in a classic way
and I feel we did that with our angles
with our shots you know with our color
palette and I think in the way that
people be in the behavior of our
characters we didn't say we were in the
50s or the 60s we were people because
everybody did things the same as they do
today you know relationships their
relationship was a very forward-thinking
one and so we the behavior was was can
temporary and I mean that's what my
approach was and ours as a collective
team just an ACLU office looks like it
was probably kind of a rollicking place
in the 70s it smell both still alive
yes Mel wolf is still can you tell us
did you have any opportunity - no I
didn't it was actually I mean it's the
pressure was sort of off me because we
had tried furiously to locate him locate
pictures of him we found one picture
where there were we weren't sure which
we knew he was in the photo but we
weren't sure which one he was in the
photo because he was very elusive and
he's sort of a bit of a controversial
figure in the ACLU towards the end so we
knew a lot about him obviously I was
relying on Daniels source material for
you know and and you know his research
on him and then once we it was very fast
because once we commenced shooting he
sort of popped up via sort of some of us
ten degrees of separation everything
like oh well heard that you're playing
my wolf and he's much older gentleman
now and we'd already sort of established
the look and sort of we'd already shot
many days so his life didn't have a
mustache I didn't know we didn't so we
were sort of you know we obviously knew
you know from newspaper clippings and
things you know his general sort of
forward leaning stance at the ACLU
and some of the things that he was
starting to do which wasn't correct me
if I'm wrong it wasn't very typical of
the ACLU at the time they started to
become sort of more proactive as far as
sort of defending freedom of speech and
things like that around that time or
slightly before and he was sort of
instrumental in doing that so um you
know I had to sort of just sort of pick
a lane and and try and stay in it go
with mimis direction and Daniel's
material and sort of you know sort of
invented a little bit some of the same
barriers that young Ruth Bader Ginsburg
confronted and Turing the legal
profession or trying to women have
confronted trying to enter the directing
profession and I wonder if you felt any
kinship with her as a character in that
respect very much so I felt a lot of
commonalities with Ruth you know I've
had the door shut in my face many times
and
you know we're both Jewish women we're
both in long-term marriages
we're both Jew we've both broken the
glass ceiling in our own with our own
professions and she truly inspired me in
every possible way in in and that is why
I wanted to make this movie because she
definitely made this planet a better
place a freer place for all of us and so
I was truly I had to make the movie and
a lot has changed a lot and there's so
much more to go and that's why I think
we all made the film well I thank you
all very much for being here I thank you
all for being here